we moved to other news now President
Trump is in Japan for high-stakes talks
about trade with the US and other key
issues Air Force one landed in Tokyo
this morning the start of a four-day
visit for mr. Trump and the first lady
for all the smiles there is a deep
uneasiness between the u.s. and Japan
after the president threatened to impose
stiff tariffs on Japanese cars and parts
Ben Tracy is traveling with the
president and joins us from Tokyo this
morning Ben good morning good morning
president Trump is the first world
leader to be honored with a state visit
with Japan's new Emperor this is just
one more example of this elaborate charm
offensive by the Japanese to stay on the
good side of the often unpredictable
American president this is president
Trump's second visit here since taking
office and the Japanese are once again
rolling out the red carpet on Saturday
the president met with high-profile
Japanese business executives and on
Monday mr. Trump will be the first world
leader to meet Emperor Naruhito
installed last month after his father
abdicated the throne due to old age the
relationship with Japan and the United
States I can say for a fact has never
been stronger
it's never been more powerful never been
closer Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo
Abe a has gone out of his way to woo
president Trump a senior administration
official says Trump and eBay have now
met or spoken more than 40 times the
Prime Minister caters to the president's
preferences after a likely golf outing
tomorrow the two leaders are expected to
dine on hamburgers and at a sumo
wrestling match this weekend President
Trump will be handing out a so-called
Trump trophy to the winner there's also
business to discuss
the president says military and trade
issues are on the agenda which could
include Japan agreeing to buy more
American military hardware including
f-35 fighter jets but it's a potential
military conflict in the Middle East
that has the president's attention we
want to have protection the Middle East
we're going to be sending a relatively
small number of troops mostly protective
the Pentagon announced Friday it is
sending an additional 900
troops to beefed up defenses after
blaming Iran for recent attacks the US
has also deployed b-52 bombers and an
aircraft carrier to the region Trump
administration is declaring an emergency
over Iran and says it will now sell more
arms to Saudi Arabia a move Congress had
previously blocked mr. Trump thinks Iran
gets the message right now they no I
don't think Iran wants to fight and I
certainly don't think they want to fight
with us of course it is Memorial Day
weekend and President Trump does expect
to visit a u.s. naval base here in Japan
on Tuesday before he heads home Anthony
Ben Tracy Thank You Ben